With his strategic moves and secretive whispers,
Otto Hightower is definitely reminding some
"House of the Dragon" fans of some of the
shrewdest players on "Game of Thrones."
Throughout the first four episodes of "House
of the Dragon," which serves as both a spin-off
of and a prequel to the HBO juggernaut "Game
of Thrones," plenty of characters are vying
for the Iron Throne, including Otto Hightower.
As Hand of the King to Viserys I as well as
two other kings before him, Otto knows what
it's like to be in close proximity to ultimate
power.
Much like Tywin Lannister from the original
"Game of Thrones," Otto is a quiet yet skilled
schemer, frequently holding his tongue until
the right moment where he can play his cards
accordingly.
By Episode 4, this tactic has succeeded nicely
for him, as his daughter Alicent Hightower
is now married to Viserys and has had two
children — one of which is a boy.
"Hail, hail!
Aegon the conqueror babe, second of his name!"
In the fourth episode of "House of the Dragon,"
"King of the Narrow Sea," Otto doesn't do
a whole lot, but he does make one crucial
move just before it draws to a close.
After Princess Rhaenyra and Prince Daemon
Targaryen give into their desire for one another
in a brothel in King's Landing, a confidante
referred to as the "White Worm" tells Otto
that the uncle and niece were spotted together.
Otto quickly takes this information to Viserys.
The king dismisses this information as nothing
more than a transparent ploy to get Alicent's
son Aegon onto the throne instead of Rhaenyra.
That said, Viserys later makes it clear to
Rhaenyra that he does possibly believe Otto.
"The truth does not matter, Rhaenyra!
Only perception!"
Even with Viserys' potential belief that Otto's
information was true, Otto is essentially
fired as Hand of the King.
But he still has plenty of cards up his sleeve.
His daughter Alicent is still the beloved
second queen to Viserys, and at the rate she's
going, she might end up giving birth to another
heir before long.
Plus, Aegon is certainly a viable candidate
for King.
Also, Otto may well have a stronger influence
the further he gets from the throne, working
from the shadows to achieve his goals.
The show has frequently alluded to the fact
that he has collaborators lurking in Oldtown;
maybe we'll finally get to see what alliances
he's formed there.
Throughout the series thus far, Otto has shown
himself to be shrewd to, perhaps, a fault.
In the aftermath of Viserys' wife's death,
he wastes little to no time in sending Alicent
to "comfort" the king, resulting in a betrothal
between the teenage girl and much older, physically
ailing Viserys.
He also even suggests to Viserys that Rhaenyra
— for whom Viserys is desperately trying
to find a suitable husband — marry her younger
half-brother Aegon, who is, at that point,
two years old.
Viserys might have fallen for Alicent's nightly
visits, but even he's disgusted by Otto's
proposition to marry Rhaenyra and Aegon.
All in all, Otto's tactics are likely to remind
fans of Petyr "Littlefinger" Baelish as well
as Tywin Lannister.
He's also definitely grossing audiences out.
What he does next remains to be seen, but
now that he's no longer Hand, he may have
to return to Oldtown to rally the troops he
apparently has there.
So we may get to revisit that location before
long.